il a dit vous savez c'est un peu comme
un
braconnier qui part à la chasse il prend
ses outils et il sait pas si le soir il
ramènera un faisant ou un
[Musique]
lapin
Michel
Fourniret celui que la presse a surnommé
l'ogre des Ardennes aimait partir à la
chasse comme il disait la chasse aux
jeunes filles
vierges
Monique Olivier son épouse a tout de
suite adhéré à son projet macabre c'est
elle qui par sa présence rassurante
rabattait et préparait les victimes que
son mari violait et étranglait c'est
elle qui lui a permis de faire autant de
victime et aussi
parfaitement la plus jeune avait 12 ans
la plus âgée 21 ans il y a eu 7 victime
mais les épous fournirai en ont
peut-être fait bien plus on pourrait
avoir un nombre important de une
vingtaine peut-être plus l'enquête sur
le couple fournirait ne cesse de
rebondir comme une histoire sans
fin avec imengali nous avons décidé de
retrouver les protagonistes de cette
affaire et d'analyser avec eux les
conséquences et les répercussions de ce
dossier hors
norme France interre 28 ans après les
fait Michel fourniré à vous de nouveaux
meurtres Michel fourniré est déjà en
prison à perpétuité pour cette aut
meurtre tout commence le 16 mai 2000 à
Charleville mière ce jour-là Céline
saison une jeune fille de 18 ans
disparaît à la sortie de son lycée on a
décidé d'aller au commissarat central de
charlevine mère vers 22h il nous a été
répondu mais vous savez elle est majeure
donc elle a le droit de
partir 2 mois et demi après sa
disparition le corps de Céline est
retrouvé dans un bois en
Belgique à quelques kilomètres de
Charleville
mière un an plus tard toujours dans les
ardenes cette fois-ci à Sedan c'est
managia tumpong une fillette de 13 ans
qui elle aussi disparaît après avoir
passé l'après-midi à la médiathèque elle
y fait ses devoirs en sort vers 17h et
puis plus rien comme volatilisé dit sa
mère moi j'ai très très peu mainant j'ai
mal j'ai mal je vis plus je il que ça je
pe dire maintenant pour moi j'ai
j'espère poli lu il va trouver qu cas
food pour je peux trouver ma fille quoi
la disparition de la petite manana est
prise très au sérieux par les
[Musique]
enquêteurs en mars 2002 un promeneur
découvre un crâne dans une forêt de
Belgique après analyse il est
identifié c'est celui de
manania les mois passent et les enquêtes
sur les meurtres de séine et manania
sont dans
[Musique]
l'impasse fin juin 2003 un homme est
arrêté en Belgique bonsir bonsoir à tous
en était-il à son premier enlèvement ou
a-t-il déjà sévi par le passé et si oui
que sont devenu ses victimes voilà les
question que se posent les enquêteurs
après l'arrestation d'un homme qui a
tenté d'enlever une jeune fille de 13
ans jeudi
dernier la jeune fille s'appelle Marie
elle raconte qu'elle a été enlevée par
un homme au volant d'une fourgonnette
blanche il m'a attaché les mains avec
les pieds et tout le corps derrière avec
la camionnette et j'ai commencé à prier
là et
je sais pas j'ai réussi à enlever les
[Musique]
liens Marie parvient miraculeusement à
s'enfuir avant d'être recueilli par une
automobiliste
elle roule vers le bureau de police et
par hasard elle croise la camionnette de
l'auteur des
fait la petite reconnait la camionnette
et la dame qui conduit à le réflexe de
relever le numéro de plaque en croisant
la
camionnette cette fourgonnette
appartient à une
femme Monique Olivier l'épouse d'un
certain Michel
Fourniret une perquisition est
immédiatement effectuée au domicile du
couple et leur camionnette passé au
peneofin les policiers font une
découverte capitale une découverte qui
va LAN la faire
fournir là on retrouve un cheveux une
structure particulière et atypique dans
le type
asiatique c'est exactement les mêmes
cheveux au niveau morphologique que les
cheveux de référence
de Michel fournir estil impliqué dans la
mort de Mania et dans celle de cine
saon l'hypothèse est
plausible il en a le
profil
né à Sedan Michel Fourniret à tout juste
24 ans quand il commet ses premiers
attouchements sur une mineure à l'époque
il est ouvrier marié et père d'un enfant
ses attouchements lui valent une
condamnation et un
divorce Fourniret s'installe alors en
région parisienne se remarie et à trois
enfants mais à 42 ans Michel Fourniret
recommence
[Musique]
nouvelle agression sexuelle et nouvelle
arrestation devant les policiers il
n'avoue pas une agression mais 15 15
agressions sexuelles commises entre
1977 et 1984 qui reconnaît en fait des
agressions sexuelles des attentats à la
pudeur un certain nombre de de violences
commises donc préjudice de de jeune
fille il utilise une fiole qu' dit être
remplie d' ou de vitriol qui s'avra en
fait être de l'eau il est menacé
éventuellement avec un pistolet
aussi au psychiatre qu' l'examine
fournirait dévoile son obsession la
virginité une obsession qui remonterait
à ses 21 ans quand il a découvert que sa
première épouse n'était plus
vierge il théorise entre guillemets ce
qu'il fait en disant voilà pourquoi je
le fais à partir du moment où où il se
prévut de sa théorie il raconte
tout en
1986 alors qu'il est en prison depuis 2
ans Michel Fourniret rencontre Monique
Olivier après avoir passé une petite
annonce Monique lui a
répondu une relation épistolaire
s'ensuit en juin 87 Michel Fourniret est
condamné à 7 ans de prison pour la série
de viol et d'agression sexuelle qu'il a
reconnu mais Fourniret qui a déjà fait
de la préventive est libéré à mi-pine il
quitte fleurerogis dès octobre
1987 au bras de Monique
Olivier le couple en ménage dans un bon
isolé à floin un petit village des
Ardennes c'est un coupe bizarre on
aurait dit comme un frère et une
sœur ils étaient ensemble depuis pas
longtemps pourtant c'était pas le grand
amour on aa l'impression qu'il vivaient
comme des vieux de pas de communication
pratiquement pas de sourire pas de pas
de blague pas rien du tout on peut on a
l'impression qu'il vivait pas il se
marie pourtant et donne naissance à un
petit garçon le trè fils Dominique
Olivier et le 5è enfant de Michel
Fourniret en
1989 la famille quitte son cabanon pour
s'installer dans un château un
changement de vie qui attire l'attention
de la police quelqu'un qui achète un
château en pleine nature à 600 m de la
frontière belge c'est c'est quelqu'un
qui vient comment on dit dans se m au
vert il fallait s'intéresse à fournirer
savoir d'où d'où cet argent
provenait fournirit à de l'argent mais
aussi des amis qui ont des relations
dans le
milieu en prison il a partagé sa cellule
avec un certain Jean-Pierre elgarche un
braqueur soupçonné d'entretenir des
liens avec Action
Directe les époux fournirai cacherait
peut-être l'un des terroristes dans leur
château la justice ordonne une
acquisition du domaine qui se solde par
un simple redressement
fiscal un ans plus tard la famille
abandonne brusquement son château pour
filer en Belgique dans le village de
sarcustine c'est ce passé chargé et
encore trouble que les policiers belges
et français découvrent lorsqu'ils
ouvrent leur enquête sur l'enlèvement de
Marie et les meurtres de managia et
Céline
les deux services de police ne vont plus
lâcher le couple durant des mois Michel
fournir et Monique Olivier sont
régulièrement
entendus on a décidé de la rencontrer le
plus souvent possible de le faire parler
de toutouer de n'importe quoi partant du
principe que quand on ment plus on parle
on finit par se
contredire les mois passent et la
pression s'accentue mais aucun des épous
ne craque jusqu'au 22 juin 2004
ce jour-là Monique Olivier est convoqué
une nouvelle fois au
commissariat on lui laisse raconter ce
qu'elle a envie de raconter sans la
brusquer ça risqué qu'elle se referme et
puis là elle nous dénonce son mari comme
aant enlevé et tué cine saison
et Monique Olivier a craqué elle a mis
en cause son mari dans les deux meurtres
mais elle va aller beaucoup plus
loin là euh en une trentaine de minutes
elle va nous mettre en cause fournira
dans 6 meurtres
elle va nous parler d'Isabelle
Laville Isabelle Laville une adolescente
de 17 ans qui a disparu 7 ans plus tôt
le 11 décembre
1987 à la sortie de son collège à osser
et puis nous cite aussi
Brichet ellisabeth Brichet 12 ans
disparu en Belgique à Namur en 198
9 Monique Olivier cite aussi
Jeanne-Marie des rame une fille de 20
ans disparu également en 89 à
Charleville Maisière
elle parle aussi d'une femme de 30 ans
qui a disparu dans les ivelines une
certaine Farida
amich Monique Olivier ne s'arrête
plus elle va nous parler de
[Musique]
Natacha le roi à
Montmelon on s'est presque posé des
question de savoir si elle nous
inventait pas des fait tellement c'était
énorme placé en garde à vue Michel
Fourniret confirme les accusations de
son épouse il a bien tué les h jeunes
[Musique]
femmes 2 jours après ses aveux fournir
et remis aux autorités françaises pour
rechercher deux corps qu'il dit avoir
enterré dans le parc de son château
celui de jeann-emarie des Rameau et
celui d'Élisabeth Brichet disparu toutes
les deux 15 ans plus
tôt sur place Michel fournirait balade
les
enquêteurs mais après 8h de fouille on
aperçoit la mange du vêtement que Pora
ellisabeth au moment de sa disparition
et que tous les enquêteurs ont en tête
c'est un Anor de couleur
[Musique]
parme le corps d'Élisabeth est enterré à
3 m de profondeur dans sa poche sa carte
d'identité et son agenda d'é
[Musique]
colières dans l'allée les pellteuses
dégagent ensuite le corps de jeanemarie
des RAM identifié grâce à la robe grise
qu'elle portait le jour de sa
disparition
là maintenant l'enquête elle vient de
passer un cap on a la preuve que les
aveux sont exactes maintenant on peut on
peut creuser partout à tout point de
[Musique]
vue au policiers comme au psychiatre
fournirait raconte en détail la manière
dont il a traqué ses victimes avant de
les violer et de les
[Musique]
tuer il était tellement intarissable que
c'était
insoutenable fallait vraiment le vouloir
pour rester dans la cellule avec lui si
il expliquait quelque chose ça aurait un
certain intérêt mais il n'explique pas
il vous fait voir ses
[Musique]
crimes les enquêteurs s'interrogent
aussi sur le rôle exact de l'épouse du
tueur en série Monique elle était au
courant de tout et elle aurait même
participé à certains
enlèvements Monique Olivier devient
complice face aux enquêteurs elle avoue
finalement qu'elle a épaulé son mari au
cours de plusieurs enlèvement comme
celui d'Isabelle
Laville c'est elle qui enlève Isabelle
la ville elle est seule dans la voiture
elle s'arrête à hauteur d'Isabelle
Laville et réussi à la faire monter dans
la voiture puis quelques dizaines de
mètres plus loin elle fait semblant de
prendre Fourniret en stop il est là il
attend avec un bidon vide et puis
Fourniret entre et puis finit par tuer
la gamine
[Musique]
quoi 19 ans après sa disparition les
ossems d'Isabelle Laville sont retrouvés
sur les indications du couple au fond
d'un puit dans
Lyonne en revanche en l'absence de corps
la justice n'a que très peu d'éléments
sur la mort de Farida amich l'affaire
n'est donc pas renvoyée avec les autres
dossiers l'instruction se clos sur les
meurtres de se jeunes
filles le procès de Michel Fourniret et
Monique Olivier s'ouvre en mars 2008
devant la Cour d'assise de Charleville
Maisière tous les regards sont braqués
sur le couple c'est une Monique Olivier
faosé qui fait la première son entrée
dans le
box Monique Olivier apparaît maquillé
les cheveux coupés coiffé du mascara sur
les yeux un visage plus avenant mais un
visage de
cire Michel Fourniret lui refuse de se
laisser filmer comme il refuse de
participer à son procès et même d'être
défendu on a un accusé sur lequel on a
aucune prise parce qu'il n'a rien à
craindre il n'a rien à craindre parce
qu'il sait que le pire va lui
arriver il affiche sur le sur le box un
papier sur lequel il a écrit 108 clos
bouche
cousu et ça c'était son ultime chantage
il voulait démontrer que c'était lui qui
décidait et qu'il ne parlerait que quand
il aurait décidé et que lorsqu'on serait
passé lorsqu'on aurait accepté ces
conditions la Cour ne plie pas et Michel
fournirait qu'on sent finalement à parlé
avec un cynisme
terrifiant lorsque je l'interpelle sur
la préparation du meurtre d'Isabelle
est-ce qu'il l'avait repéré les lieux ou
pas il m'a répondu quelque chose
d'horrible il a dit vous savez c'est un
peu comme un
braconnier qui part à la chasse il prend
ses outils et il sait pas si le soir il
ramènera un faisant ou un
lapin Monique Olivier son épouse est
toujours aussi
glaçante ce qui choque tout le monde
c'est que des jeunes filles vont monter
sans méfiance dans la camionnette de
fourn parce que madame est là parce que
Monique Olivier est
là
par sa présence rassurante elle permet à
à Fourniret de les
embarquer il y a une reconstitution qui
a été projetée au procès de la toilette
intime de la petite Élisabeth Brichet
qui qui a ses règles que va pratiquer
Monique Olivier sur elle c'est un truc
terrible elle va rejouer cette scène sur
une poupée de chiffon qui qui est
attaché les bras en croix sur un lit
elle elle couvre d'un drap et puis elle
descend la cuisine et elle dit à Michel
Fourniret ça y est elle est prête elle
lui
livre avant sa rencontre avec Monique
Olivier Fourniret avait violé mais il
n'avait jamais tué sans elle serurait-il
passé à
l'acte il aurait tué sans elle mais il
aurait probablement tué plus tard de
manière beaucoup plus imparfaite et il
se serait fait prendre beaucoup plus tôt
comme c'est le cas à la fin quand il
agit sans elle il était dans la
perversion mais il n'était pas dans la
perfection avec elle il a atteint les
deux et la perversion et la
perfection après 2 mois d'audience
Monique Olivier est condamnée à
perpétuité avec 28 ans de
[Musique]
sûreté Michel Fourniret est condamné à
la plus lourde peine prévue par le code
pénal la réclusion PERP
[Musique]
incompressible aujourd'hui les
enquêteurs continuent de retracer le
parcours criminel du couple fournirit si
certaines affaires conservent encore
leur mystère d'autres sont enfin en
cours de
résolution comme le crime de Farida
amiche commis en
1988 avoué par Monique Olivier et
reconnu par Michel fourniray un crime
longtemps resté une
[Musique]
énigme Patricia touranchot qui est
Farida amich Farida amich était la
compagne de Jean-Pierre elgarche un
codétenu de Michel Fourniret quand ils
étaient ensemble en sellu la fleurogis
et en fait euh elgouarche le braqueur
avait pris un peu sous son aelle sous sa
protection Michel Fourniret le
[Musique]
pointeur ce Jean-Pierre elgouarche
pendant sa détention a eu vent qu'un
trésor une partie du magot du fameux
gang des postiches était dissimulé dans
un cimetière
il ne peut pas sortir tout de suite de
prison il pense qu'il faut quand même
pas trop laisser traîner cette histoire
et il charge sa compagne d'entrer en
contact avec Fourniret dans le but
d'aller récupérer ce
[Musique]
trésor une nuit de mars 88 Farida amich
et Michel Fourniret accompagné de
Monique Olivier sont partis dans ce
cimetière du valdoise pour déterrer le
le
magot ils sont allés chez elgoire chez
Farida fournirait effectivement aménager
une cache au-dessus des WC pour planquer
tout
[Musique]
ça en échange de quoi Farida lui a remis
comme prévu l'équivalent de 500000
francs en lingot et en pièce
d'or
le deal pourrait s'arrêter là tout le
monde y trouverait son compte mais
Michel Fourniret et Monique Olivier
estime que finalement il y a sûrement
une affaire bien plus juteuse à faire et
un mois plus tard le le 12 avril 88
exactement fournirait attendu un piège à
Farida lui a demandé un service en
urgence est-ce que tu peux m'aider à
déménager des armes que j'ai caché en
forêt
[Musique]
rambouillé y vons avec la voiture de
Farida Monique Olivier suivant derrière
avec la voiture des
fournirets arrivé dans les ivelines du
côté de Clairefontaine il demande à à
Farida de de
descendre et il l'achève en
l'étranglant et il abandonné son corps à
la sortie d'un village en bas d'une
pente il l'a enseveli d' espèce de
fossée ils sont retournés chez ELG chez
Farida ils ont volé l'intégralité du
magot ils sont allés abandonner la
voiture de Farida amich sur le parking
de l'aéroport d'Orly pour faire croire
en fait que Farida avait disparu avec un
mec et avec
l'argent un an plus tard en
1989 Jean-Pierre elgarch sort de
prison il a un petit doute il se dit dit
quand même les les derniers à priori
avoir vu Farida c'est quand même les
fournirai et il débarque à l'improviste
dans la maison des Fourniret leur espèce
de masure à flouin dans les Ardennes
elgardge dira sur procèsverbal quand je
les ai vu c'était les Ténardiers avec
leurs gosses c'était des pauvres mais
des vrais pauvres ENF les Fourniret lui
ont fait le coup la pauvreté et ça a
[Musique]
marché au détour d'un interrogatoire sur
ces liens possibl avec le groupe Action
direct Jean-Pierre elgarch apprend que
les fournira viennent de s'acheter un
château à cet instant il comprend qu'il
s'est fait doubler
elgouarche est comme un dingue il fonce
dans les Ardennes il trouve ce château
de du Sautou il il pénètre dans la
propriété à ce moment-là fournira
comprend ce qui se passe elgarche tire
un coup de feu fournira se barre en
voiture il neapparaîtra
plus 10 ans après la disparition de sa
compagne Jean-Pierre elgarche dépose
plainte contre les
fourniris l'affaire est classée sans
suite en quelques
[Musique]
mois
maître Corin Herman pourquoi cette
plainte n'a-telle pas été prise au
sérieux parce que le parquet a vérifié
où habitait Michel fourneriret puisquil
était nommé Michel fourneret habitait en
Belgique ils ont considéré qu'il ne
pouvait pas aller chercher en Belgique
alors Michel fourniray et Monique
Olivier ont pourtant avoué ce crime en
2004 et ça n'a pas relancé l'enquête ça
a relancé l'enquête mais elle a été très
très lente on l'a mise sur le bas côté
des autres affaires et pu peut-être
parce que c'était la femme d'un Truant
on préférait ne pas la mélanger il a eu
le sentiment que on ne lui rendrait pas
justice d'une certaine manière parce
qu'il avait
lui-même commis un certain nombre de
faits qu' l'avait amené devant les
tribunaux or le meurt d'une femme
qu'elle soit la femme d'un Truant ou
qu'elle soit la femme d'un honnet homme
c'est la même chose c'est aussi terrible
et ça justifie évidemment qu'il y ait
une sanction
pénale en 2009 l'assassinat de Farida
amich est prescrit mais les avocats de
Jean-Pierre elgarche montent au
pour secouer la justice
elle considérait qu'il y avait pas eu
d'acte d'instruction à l'époque et que
ce dossier ne faisait pas partie de la
série criminelle de Michel Fourniret
mais en réalité il en fait totalement
partie il a même permis de financer ses
activités criminelles et de financer
finalement les autres crimes un exemple
tout simple il a acheté un château dans
le sur le terrain de ce château il a
enterré deux corps c'était s'il a pu
acheter ce château c'est grâce au Mago
donc c'est même le crime qui a permis
les autres
crimes un raisonnement que la Cour de
cassation décide de suivre en 2011 elle
écarte la
prescription le couple est renvoyé
devant les assises Michel fournirit pour
assassinat et recelle de V la main armée
Monique Olivier pour complicité
d'assassinat et
recel le procès doit avoir lieu en
novembre
[Musique]
maître Vavasseur vous êtes l'avocat
commis d'office de Michel Fourniret dans
le dossier amich pour vous il y a bien
prescription dans ce dossier il a été
sauvé des EAU parce qu'on a
effectivement indiqué qu'il y avait une
connexité avec le
recel de l'or qu'il a pu récupérer au
moment du du meurtre de Farida amich
effectivement c'est une règle qui
n'apparaît nulle part dans le code de
procédure pénale mais qui résulte d'une
jurisprudence qui a été finalement à mon
sens créée pour les besoins de la cause
donc je conteste malgré tout l'effet de
recelle de vol dans la mesure où je
considère que Monsieur fournir n'a
aucune connaissance de l'origine des de
l'or qu'il a pu récupérer et dans la
mesure où finalement rien nétablit que
ce cet or provienne des vols du gang des
postiches vous pensez vraiment que
Michel Fourniret va s'exprimer je ne
sais pas exactement comment il se
comporte portera devant la Cour d'Assise
mais j'espère qu'il qu'il parlera même
si à tout moment je pense qu'un
rebondissement est possible je rappelle
que dans ce dossier àich il a refusé de
s'exprimer essayant si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi de monayer sa parole
contre des service est-ce qu'il pourrait
refuser de comparaître je pense qu'il a
un certain plaisir intellectuel à se
confronter à ce genre de chos donc je
pense qu'il sera là comment est-ce qu'on
défend quelqu'un qui de toute façon va
passer sa vie en prison c'est vrai que
la peine
n'aura pas une énorme importance si ce
n'est d'un point de vue moral donc on ne
veut pas non plus prendre le maximum
parce que c'est Monsieur fournir on va
avoir une juste une juste sanction d'un
dossier
[Musique]
isolé Richard deljeunesse votre cliente
va être jugée comment appréhende-t-elle
ce procès elle a déjà reconnu ité des
faits dans l'affaire de décès de Madame
Farida amich il est peu probable qu'elle
revienne sur ce qu'elle a dit et ce
qu'elle a reconnu par
contre plus intimement Monique Olivier a
peur de Michel fourniray il y a une
appréhension de se retrouver tout près
de lui dans le box une appréhension de
le voir de le retrouver et en plus c'est
un pervers qui je pense aime bien
s'amuser avec les uns et les autres et
s'il voit qu'avec peut s'amuser il
n'hésitera pas à le faire à un moment
donné donc voilà elle le sait le corps
de faridaich n'a toujours pas été
trouver votre cliente sait où il se
trouve Monique Olivier a lorsqu'elle a
fait ses aveux a donné tout ce qu'elle
avait comme information si elle les a
pas donné c'est parce qu'elle n'en a pas
de souvenir ou que les lieux ont
[Musique]
changé maettre ce ban qu'attend
Jean-Pierre elgarche de ce procès que
Michel Fourniret dise le lieu où il a
enterré Farida que ce secret ne ne soit
pas emporté par Michel Fourniret et
Monique Olivier qu'on puisse retrouver
son corps qu'on puisse l'enterrer
dignement Michel Fourniret a été
condamné à la peine maximal ce nouveau
procès ne changera en
rien sa
situation pour lui sur sa situation de
détenenstion très certainement pour
Monique Olivier c'est différent
puisquelle elle peut être libérée donc
il y a un enjeu peut-être plus fort pour
elle que pour lui et puis euh il n'y a
pas que l'enjeu de la peine il y a
l'enjeu de dire une vérité judicière les
familles attendent des
[Musique]
réponses deux autres affaires non
résolues pourraient connaître un
dénouement judiciaire le meurtre de
Johanna parich en mai
1990 et la disparition en juillet 1988
de Marie-Angèle domes une jeune femme de
19 ans qui vivait dans un foyer à
[Musique]
osser Véronique domes pourquoi
Marie-Angèle a-t-elle été placée en
foyer parce que ma mère a eu un accident
euh ma sœur était était toute petite
dans un Land ma mère était sur sur une
nationale et elle s'est fait percuter
par la moto donc le motard est mort ma
mère s'est retrouvé à l'hôpital et ma
petitesœur à l'hôpital aussi donc les
services sociaux ont repris Marie-Angèle
et donc ma mère a pas été déchute ses
droit puisqu'elle avait toujours un
droit de visite mais sa fille lui était
retirée quand est-ce que vous avez vu
votre sœur pour la dernière fois
décembre
[Musique]
87 le dernier Noël qu'on a fait au foyer
on a été dansé au foyer avec elle et ses
copines comment est-ce que vous avez
appris sa disparition par les
journaux Claude demes dans quelles
circonstances marieangèle a-t-elle
disparu je suis laendé au foyer j'ai eu
un entretien avec une une personne de
l'encadrement qui était là et qui m'a
simplement dit que elle était elle était
partie quoi elle était sortie du foyer à
une HE normale et qu'elle avait pas
rejoint son train puisque il y avait pas
de trace à la gare ni rien du tout voilà
c'est tout quelles sont selon vous les
hypothèses qui pourrai expliquer la
disparition de votre fille tout d'abord
j'ai pensé que
elle était peut-être partie en fugue
avec quelqu'un euh à certain moment j'ai
pens pvit avoir ét enlevé mais je me
demander un peu aussi par qui comment
pourquoi et comment on pu la repérer
est-ce que vous avez déposé plainte chez
les gendarmes non j'ai pas déposé
plainte parce que marieang é à l'époque
j'ai pensé à d'ailleurs
que moi son père je n'avais pas le
droitinvenir à son sujet que la priorité
revenait au représentant de la
[Musique]
mettre ce ban la disparition de
Marie-Angèle domess a été signalée à la
DAS que s'est-il passé à l'époque
malheureusement la la justice de de de
Lyonne tout comme les services d'enquête
ne se passent complètement à côté la
disparition de marieangèle deèche il y a
une enquête extrêmement limitée un
nonlieu est délivré en février 89 8 mois
seulement après la disparition de de
Marie Angèle quelles sont les
conclusions de ce nonlieu au faut qu'on
ne saura pas qu'elle est partie qu'elle
a sûrement vécu sa vie et puis qu'on n'
pas d'élément qui donnent un caractère
criminel à l'affaire l'histoire pour
nous était classée qu on saurait jamais
ce qui était devenue
marie-angène à l'époque dans Lyonne une
autre affaire piétine celle du meurtre
d'une jeune Anglaise de 20 ans Johanna
parich étudiante en littérature Johanna
s'était installée à oser en
1989 son corps est retrouvé dans les
eaux de Lyonne en mai 1990 Corin Herman
que donne l'enquête sur la mort de cette
jeune femme au départ on va chercher
effectivement on va chercher de façon
plus détaillée que pour Marie-Angèle
Domche c'est vrai qu'on va faire
quelques investigations puis c'est une
famille anglaise on lui doit lui doit
une réponse il y a évidemment des
pressions diplomatiques donc on va
chercher un petit peu plus longuement
mais finalement très vite on va
abandonner le dossier en 92 93 on laisse
ouvert mais on abandonne les recherches
on abandonne les investigations donc
très longtemps il se passera
rien les enquêtes sur la mort de Johanna
parich et la disparition de marieangèle
domes restent au point mort jusqu'à ce
que Monique Olivier se décide à parler
en
2005 il faut remettre les aveux de des
affaires Paris chez Domche dans la
chronologie des désaveux de Monique
Olivier Michel fournir est en
détenenstion depuis plusieurs mois pour
une tentative de kidnapping d'une jeune
fille en Belgique et les enquêteurs
commencent à penser que Michel fir
disimile autre chose qu'une tentative de
de kidnapping et ils se disent que le
levier peut-être Monique Olivier donc
elle va être auditionnée plusieurs fois
et elle va passer aux aveux dans deux
affaires particulières qui sont pas
riche et domèche que dit-elle au sujet
de ces deux jeunes femmes qu'est-ce
qu'elle raconte Monique Olivier on peut
considérer que les déposit monque
Olivier sures les affaires Paris chez
domes sont sensiblement
identiques à aux autres affaires des des
des autres jeunes filles est-ce que sont
des
éléments suffisamment circonstanciés
pour être certain que les aveux sont des
vrais aveux faudrait demander au j
instruction malgré ces accusations
Michel Fourniret nit
farouchement pourtant en juin 2007 alors
que son procès devant la Cour d'Assise
se profile
fournirait adresse un étrange courrier
au
magistrat il demande à être jugé pour
les dossiers Joan parich marieangel
domèche en même temps que les autres
crimes il dit qu'il est l'auteur des
faits à sa façon avec ses mots mais il
dit qu'il est l'auteur des faits il
donne juste une précision de plus il
indique qu'il se tient à la disposition
des enquêteurs pour les aider à aller
très vite dans ses enquêtes pour
qu'elles puissent être jugé avec les
autres pourquoi cette forme d'aveu tout
à coup en 2007 il y a une pression
autour de ce procès qui est terrible il
se sent un peu plus vieux il se sent
dépassé un peu par les événements quand
même et il se dit que il a peur de
mourir et que peut-être les familles
n'auraient pas de réponse est-ce qu'il a
une HCE d'humanité je ne le sais pas je
saurais pas me proncer là-dessus mais en
tous les cas c'est ce qui nous dit il
veut pas s'il meurt laisser cet héritage
à ses enfants il veut reconnaître ces
faitsl mais l'instruction est terminée
et le procès est
audiancé la cour d'assise de Charleville
mère refuse de rentrer dans le jeu de
Michel Fourniret il faut attendre le 11
mars 2008 pour que le couple Fourniret
soit mise en examen pour le meurtre de
Johanna parich et la disparition de
Marie-Angèle domes deux dossiers
fragiles d'autant que Monique Olivier
est revenu sur ses déclarations et niit
désormais tout implication de son mari
dans ces deux crimes elle dit que ces
deux faitsl qu'elle a pu avouer elle
revient dessus parce qu'elle a été
malmené et qu'on lui a dit ces affaires
là voilà il y a deux affaires là qu'on
n' pas élucidé c'est Michel fourneré
comment les choses sont présentées elle
dit non dit mais si allez allez on va
pas tourner là-dessus il faut les
reconnaître et cetera elle a été
secoué physiquement donc là après elle
dit bah oui c'est ça et elle dit qu'on
lui donnait les questions réponses
qu'elle dit c'est qu'elle a avoué les
crimes qu'ils avaient bien commis et
qu'on l'a forcé à reconnaître ces deuxl
mon olivier dit effectivement qu'on elle
a reconnu des faits des meurtres et que
sur ces deuxl ils lui ont été amenés
VO faute de preuve en septembre 2011 la
justice prononce un non lieu dans ces
deux
affaires quand on nous a annoncé non
lieu ça s'est
passé devant un jugeinstruction qui
d'abord nous a dit voilà dans le dossier
il y a strictement rien on a ouvert un
carton devant nous il y avait rien quand
je suis sorti làdedans était plutôt
lesésappointés j'était euh je me
demandais bien comment on allait faire
si on voulait pouvoir faire quelque
chose on parlait de criminel qui venaent
d'être condamné pour cet assassinat et
ça n'est pas normal de rendre un nonlieu
sur ce type de tueur en série c'est
incroyable on oublie que le couple est
évidemment dans Lyonne à cette époque-là
parce qu' il est en train de débarrasser
un héritage
de la famille de Michel Fourniret on
oublie que ses premiers meurtres à la
sortie de prison il est commet dans
Lyonne on oublie qu'il y a des traces
sur le corps de Johanna parich qui font
exactement penser aux traces qu'on a
retrouvé sur d'autres meurtres qu'
commis Michel fournirit on oublie que
Marie-Angèle Domche se rend
régulièrement à saint-ciier les colons
où habite la mère de Michel Fourniret où
est la maison de Michel Fourniret on
oublie
tout en juin 2012 les avocats des
familles obtiennent finalement gain de
cause les deux dossiers sont repris
depuis le
début les gendarmes de la section de
recherche de Dijon vérifient à nouveau
l'emploi du temps de fournirai il
recoupe toutes les auditions un travail
considérable qui finit par
payer en février 2018 Michelle fournir
parle enfin dans les dossiers
Marie-Angèle domes et Joanna
parich maîre ce ban pourquoi fournirait
ce décidetil subitement à parler parce
que il le dit il le redit si les
enquêteurs ne travaillent pas je vais
quand même pas leur donner des affaires
sur lequelles ils n'ont pas travaillé
donc comme il on av'ait pas travaillé
jusque- là il n'a pas avoué donc on a
travaillé on arrive avec des résultats
tangibles des éléments précis qu'il
mettent en cause et sur son emploi du
temps il avoue Corine Herman que dit
Michel fournirit à la juge d'instruction
il dit simplement que si ces femmes
n'avaient pas croiser sa route elle
serait vivante aujourd'hui pour le reste
l'enquête se poursuit donc c'est
difficile de donner d'autres détails
mais il est très clair sur ce point là
c'est comme ça qu'il avoue c'est de
cette façon qu'il avoue si elle ne
m'avait pas rencontré elle serait
toujours vivante si elle ne m'avait pas
croisé si elle n'avait pas croisé ma
route elle serait toujours vivante
est-ce qu'il implique Monique Olivier
danses
aveux d'une certaine
façon quel crédit peut-on apporter aux
aveux de Michel
fourniray un crédit total parce que
Michel fourniiret n'a jamais avoué des
faits qu'il n'a pas commis lorsqu'il a
avoué des faits ils ont toujours été
vérifiés qu'après il puisse jouer sur
des détails il l'a toujours fait il peut
le faire mais ses aveux sont pour moi
certains est-ce qu'il y a des éléments
dans le dossier qui permettent de
crédibiliser ses déclarations bien sûr
qu'il y a des éléments dans le dossier
je peux affirmer mais que les que les
aveux sont corroborés par le dossier et
qu'il était confronté à un dossier qui
est parfaitement bien j'ai envie de dire
ficelé en juin
2018 nouveau coup de théâtre à la suite
des aveux de Fourniret Monique Olivier
est entendue par la juge d'instruction
sans donner les noms des victimes elle
incrim à nouveau fournirait dans deux
crimes qui pourrait bien être les
meurtres de Johanna et de
marieangèle pour nous ça ne ça ne fait
que nous conforter dans ce qui s'est
passé quoi il y a pas d'erreur il y a
plus d'erreur monsieur domes vous pensez
qu'on peut croire les aveux de Michel
Fourniret je crois quand même qu'on
approche du but je crois que Fourniret
et c'est rare parce que on connaît
l'oiseau il aime à faire souffrir les
gens il aime à faire à montrer qu'il est
le plus fort il aime a montré qu'il est
le meneur de jeu mais
mais il faudra qu'il se mette bien une
chose en tête il sera pas meneur de jeu
encore
longtemps il sera vaincu et en même
temps c'est compliqué le corps de votre
fille n'a jamais été retrouvé est-ce que
vous espérez qu'un jour Michel Fourniret
dise tiens elle est là est-ce qu'il aura
un jour si dire pensez-moi l'expression
entre guillemets la bonté de bien
vouloir dire l'endroit où il l'a déposé
où il l'a enterré où il l'a pas enterré
on n sait rien voilà jusqu'à présent on
a rien trouvé des fouilles ont eu lieu
négatif hein voilà jusqu'à l'
aujourd'hui monsieur domes qu'est-ce que
vous attendez de la justice pour
moi je serai disons tout à fait disons
heureux de voir fournirit au bon des
accusés le voir he le voir là on se
croit fort quand on attaque une gamine
hein et puis euh qu'on la
massacre c'est pas un être humain tout
intelligent qu'il soit faire les choses
comme ça je dis pas ça parce que c'est
ma fille j'ai dis ça au nom de toutes
les victimes si on me le permet
aujourd'hui je suis un peu plus
confiante que je l'étais je suis à prête
aller jusqu'au bout de du procès qu'on
sache la vérité pour Marie quoi pour
nous pour Mo pour sa
mère pour la
[Musique]
famille l'ombre du tueur en série plane
depuis des années sur la disparition
d'une autre fillette
Estelle Mousin Estelle a disparu en
région parisienne en rentrant de l'école
le 9 janvier 2003 moins de 6 mois avant
l'arrestation mich fournir de nombreuses
pistes ont été envisagées parmi elles
cell de l'ogre des
ardenes j'y fournirai il y a quand même
57 cassettes de la télé belge dont un
reportage très complet sur la
disparition d'estmousin donc ça ça
intrique beaucoup les enquêteurs de la
PG de versaill qu'est-ce qu'il fout lui
le le criminel de petite fille a
enregistrer une émission sur Estel
Mousin et puis il a le profil
en 2007 lorsque fournir a écrit à la
justice pour être entendu sur les
affaires Paris chez domes il a également
déclaré avoir des choses à dire sur
Estel
Mousin il sous-entend qu'il y ait pour
quelque chose dans cette disparition
mais la justice à l'époque n'accepte pas
de de rentrer dans ce jeu et le dossier
estmin reste à
part en effet plusieurs éléments
semblent mettre fournirit hors de cause
malgré plusieurs expertises génétiques
aucune trace ADN d''estel Mousin n'a été
retrouvée dans la fourgonnette du couple
et surtout le jour de l'enlèvement
Michel Fourniret avait un
alibi Michel Fourniret a expliqué que le
9 janvier 2003 il avait passé un appel à
20h depuis chez lui à son fils
donc chez lui c'était en Belgique à
sarcustine donc à 267 k de guerm donc
décemment s'il appelle à 20h il peut pas
être à 18h à guerm unalibi confirmé par
Monique Olivier les zones d'ombre sont
trop nombreuses pour la
justice en octobre 2013 Michel fourniet
est mis hors de
[Musique]
cause mais en 2015 nouveau
rebondissement Monique Olivier aurait
fait des confidences à une
elle lui aurait révélé avoir fourni un
alibi à son mari pour le jour de
l'enlèvement d''estel
Mousin Monique Olivier a été entendue
suite au propos tenu par la codétenue a
contesté toute toute confidence donnée à
quelqu'un voilà enfin pour elle c'est un
mensonge c'est un mensonge bien sûr et
elle n'a rien à voir avec l'affaire
Estel Mousin et Michel Fourniret non
plus Michel fournir il dit ce qu'il veut
dire Michel fournir mais ma cliente en
tout cas conteste toute implication dans
laaffire Mousin de près ou de loin et
conteste avoir donné un alibi à Michel
Fourniret en mars 2018 Fourniret se
replace au centre de l'enquête sur la
disparition des stellemousin durant
l'instruction sur l'affaire d'omes le
tueur en série aurait fait des aveux en
creux Corin Herman c'est vous qui avez
employé cette expression des aveux en
creux qu'est-ce que ça signifie c'est
c'est-à-dire qu'il ne ni pas les faits
quand il est confronté à ses faits alors
que pendant des années les a niaé avec
virulence il se metett en colère à
chaque fois qu'on reprenait ou qu'on lui
parlait du dossier d''estel Mousin là il
ne niit plus donc il ne niit pas avoir
tué Estel Mousin mais il n'avoue pas
avoir tué Estel Mousin ça c'est des
aveux en creux c'est une forme d'aveux
en creux dans la mesure où il a écrit ce
courrier en 2007 où il reconnaît où il
avoue les faits concernant Estelle
Mousin et lorsqu'il est confronté à
cette lettre il ne nit pas donc il
maintient ses aveux tels qu'il les a
écrits sur cette lettre est-ce que des
aveux en creux ça suffit ça suffit en
tout cas pour investiguer et pour aller
chercher plus loin mais ça constitue pas
de vrais aveux pour moi ça constitue des
aveux et pour la justice c'est son
[Musique]
problème Michel fournirit aurait donc
selon ses propres aveux tuer au moins 10
jeunes femmes entre 1987 et 2003 mais
Fourniret a-t-il livré tous ses secrets
non c'est certain on ne sait pas tous
des crimes de Michel fourneret combien
il y a de crimes je ne sais pas par
contre ce que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'on a trouvé de nombreuses empreintes
génétiques dans son fourgon sur des C et
ces empreintes génétiques ne sont
toujours pas identifié peut-être que
parmi ces empreintes on a les traces de
victimes pendant 10 ans au cours des
années 90 fourniiret ne fait plus parler
de lui qu'est-ce que vous en pensez lui
nous dit que il commet au moins de
crimes par an donc on pourrait avoir un
nombre important de victimes pour ces 10
ans une vingtaine peut-être plus
peut-être moins je ne sais pas personne
ne peut croire qu'il n'a pas commis de
fait entre 90 et
[Musique]
2000 Monique Olivier pourra déposer une
première demande de libération
conditionnelle en 2032
elle aura alors 84
ans quant à Michel Fourniret il est là
des rares détenus en France condamné à
la perpétuité incompressible sauf raison
médicale extrême il finira ses jours en
prison reste à savoir si d'ici là il
aura avoué d'autres
crimes